[Music]  so here in this short video we will  showcase the size comparison of all the  kaiju of the gamera movies universe  although they aren't as many as that of  the godzilla universe  the ones that are there are still  awesome while many of these kaiju are  different iterations of a single monster  we nonetheless will showcase them all as  they appear in different shapes and  sizes as the movie errors proceeds on so  let's get down to it  anyway with that we come to the end of  this video so do hit that like button  for support and subscribe as well to be  a part of the mind cue family but most  of all smash the bell icon for regular  updates on new videos right here on this  channel till the next one take care fam